derrière la porte de ce petit sas se
trouve la tête de la structure qui
permet de créer le tunnel du futur
tramouette6 mais pour creuser sur 1,6 km
le tunnelier surnommé Nolwen ressemble à
un énorme labyrinthe sur plus de 80 m un
petit train transporte les futures
parois du tunnel d'autres tapis amènent
à l'extérieur les déchets issus du
creusement pendant que des vérrains
maintiennent la pression sur les parois
toute une mécanique de plus de 1000
tonnes huilée et contrôlé à chaque
minute dans cette cabine cerveau
indispensable au fonctionnement du
tunnelier la machine peut se trouver
facilement en panne à cause de une panne
de Gru à l'extérieur une panne de
centrale à mortier une panne de
d'évacuation de déblé il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses qui font que la
machine peut se retrouver en panne d'une
minute à l'autre une dizaine de
personnes travaillent dans le tunnelier
du lundi matin 7h30 jusqu'au samedi
matin 5h nonstop l'engin progresse de
200 m par mois et devrait atteindre son
terminus la station let rive droite fin
décembre le futur tram6 assurera une
liaison interbe en lieu de 14 km entre
vioflet dans les ivelines et Châtillon
dans les hautes scèes en 40 minutes
cette nouvelle ligne en service desès
2015 facilitera les déplacements
d'environ 150000
usagers